[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya conmigo lista en el estudio
rosa pérez más de rosa bienvenida ya
estamos a miércoles
abrimos entonces esta revista de prensa
con un repaso por las portadas
británicas como ya lo veníamos hablando
en el noticiero que reaccionan a la
multa que va a tener que pagar el primer
ministro británico boris johnson por
participar en la fiestas en downing
street- nada menos durante el
confinamiento de la pandemia
buenos días raúl exactamente no y la
prensa británica entre otras cosas acusa
a boris johnson de ser el primer primer
ministro que incumple la ley estando en
el cargo también la oposición y la
prensa lo acusan de haber mentido tanto
a los ciudadanos del reino unido- como
al propio parlamento cuando en un
principio aseguró que no había
incumplido la ley y planteó a su fiesta
de cumpleaños que finalmente es por el
evento por el que ha sido multado como
tal así como su esposa y el secretario
de finanzas pues lo planteó casi como
una emboscada con una torta no raúl bien
a sin embargo a pesar de que haya voces
sobre todo dentro del partido laborista
que piden su renuncia parece que de
momento boris johnson no va a dimitir y
así lo plantea the times que dice
johnson se niega a renunciar por la
multa de las fiestas durante la pandemia
por otro lado the gardian titula no bien
bien una cita pero sí una síntesis de la
postura del primer ministro dice rompí
mi propia ley pero me niego a irme por
otro lado the independant muestra una
fotografía de la puerta del número 10 de
downing street sede del ejecutivo
británico y también de estas fiestas
durante el confinamiento y titula la
escena del crimen y por otro lado
financial times dice multas por violar
la ley del cob y añaden presión sobre
johnson y zona k continuamos en europa
rosa pero nos enfocamos en francia con
la campaña de cara al balotaje la
segunda vuelta electoral y las
dificultades de ambos candidatos
hablamos del candidato presidente manuel
macro ni también de la ultraderechista
marine pen que son los que pasaron a
esta segunda vuelta como van a ser ellos
para ampliar la base de los votantes
para poder ganar la presidencia pues
raúl tal y como hoy en oid a día de hoy
lleva a gran parte de la prensa esa la
cuestión está en una puja por el
electorado de izquierdas que se ha
quedado sin representante no de cara a
esta segunda vuelta y así lo titula
libération en portada que dice cariño he
olvidado a la izquierda con una foto de
macrón corriendo a por este electorado
no por otro lado también a lo de mon lo
lleva en portada pero hemos querido
destacar un análisis del economista tan
reconocido a nivel internacional thomas
piketty que dice sí macrón no hace un
gesto social fuerte con urgencia
entonces su arrogancia puede hacerle
perder la segunda vuelta contra el epen
dice que entre las dificultades que
tiene macrón para convencer al
electorado de izquierdas de que voten
por él esta vez también está que ha
llevado a cabo unas políticas económicas
claramente de derechas que ha entrado en
el juego de las políticas y de los
discursos identitarios de la extrema
derecha pero que lo más peligroso es la
arrogancia del presidente y que la
máxima expresión de esta arrogancia es
la reforma de las pensiones la cual la
macro no cede ahora mismo pues dispuesto
a reconsiderar oa matizar según las
últimas noticias de ayer vamos a ver
entonces qué pasa con esta carrera
presidencial alicio rosa que no me
quería quedar sin comentar este pues
esta caricatura de sushi en media parque
también va sobre lo mismo no dice en
plan mano tendida de macrón al
electorado de maranchón de ese candidato
de izquierdas que se quedó a las puertas
del balotaje no sé si lo podemos ver a
continuación ahí la tenemos a la
izquierda del todo y cuando esta mano
tendida es una mano arrancada a un
manifestante de los chalecos amarillos
este movimiento social no tan fuerte a
principios del mandato de macrón y que
fue pues reprimido con mucha violencia
policial que conllevó pues a manos
arrancadas y que fue denunciada tanto
por el parlamento europeo como por
naciones unidas o pues amnistía
internacional entre otras organizaciones
que condenaron esta violencia policial
cerramos entonces la revista de prensa
del día de hoy con una noticia un hombre
colombiano detenido en rusia acusado de
difundir información falsa sobre el
ejército ruso lo explica el most time
exactamente este medio ruso nos dice que
giraldo saray alberto enrique es de los
primeros extranjeros en ser imputado en
rusia por supuestamente haber violado
esta ley que persigue la difusión de
noticias falsas sobre el ejército ruso
una legislación recordemos creada a raíz
de esta invasión rusa de ucrania este
hombre se encuentra en prisión
provisional en moscú y el juicio se va a
celebrar el 8 de junio recordemos
enfrenta lo que puede ser una multa de
cerca de 60 mil dólares o hasta 15 años
de prisión no recuerda este artículo que
hay 20 rusos en la misma situación y
también un periodista ucraniano dimitri
gordon que también está siendo
investigado pues por supuestamente
incumplir la misma ley